Chris are we gonna be okay
absolutely Dave we're going to be okay
we have to calm down all the way around
and quit watching so much crazy stuff on
media oh my gosh ah it is scary the way
people are acting and I think that's
more scary than the actual facts I agree
and it has been for several weeks
there's stereo which is panic out of
control is not your friend yeah fat as
John Delaney says facts are your friend
yes I like that and um you know when
you're in a crisis and we obviously have
a health crisis in America we obviously
have a corresponding financial crisis
mm-hmm and and so you know bad processes
bad principles that have been in either
one of those areas and or either one of
those areas of your life are starting to
reveal themselves if you had a health
weakness of financial weakness mm-hmm it
was okay when everything was okay right
but now it's being exposed and when you
stress test stupid it comes up looking
pretty stupid stupid doesn't stress test
well and you know we get ready to do it
launched a website around here we always
stress test it they load test it right
put a load on it see if it can carry the
load before we turn it open to the
public and this is being you know some
of you your financial your best
financial ideas you know like it's
really hard right now to be really
comfortable based on your airline miles
yeah oh I agree virtually disposed yeah
so let's see those airline miles you
were trying to collect and work it's
kind of that dr. Phil moment how's that
working for you now so you know and so
you know what some of the things that
people believed about money are now
officially challenged and that is the
good news of the bad news the hard times
expose this stuff and make you say never
again sometimes you go through a
personal great depression and sometimes
the nation
goes through an actual stress time and
in 2008 a bunch of people learned their
lesson yes and I learned my lesson went
broke because I was stupid and my stupid
ideas got stressed tested I got my face
beat in and I was in my 20s and I got
the opportunity to start again with the
knowledge that that experience gave me
and some of you right now I'm not gonna
tell you I told you so but this is your
wake-up call you're going to have the
opportunity to start again with the
knowledge that this mess has given you I
completely agree Dave and we're gonna
have what you're having right now I'm
doing Instagram live each day from 11:00
11:30 we've got I'm seeing more about an
awakening for people where they go you
know they're either in two camps thank
goodness
they've for your message and I've got an
emergency fund or I was on my way or I
should have listened sooner and of those
three I keep telling people you've got
an opportunity to make this now this
information become knowledge and wisdom
when you apply it in your life but what
we have to do is now realize more than
ever that we cannot wait on the
government days to save the day I know
they're talking about all the little
stimulus packages and I tell people you
know it's gonna help but it's not gonna
continue well it's not gonna help but
it's a little bit like peeing on horse
fire I mean it's a bit of a joke I mean
it's gonna help but it's you know if a
thousand dollars saves your life well
you didn't have a life that's true and
so your financial life you know I mean
that's just absurd if payroll taxes
being removed from a business saves it
it probably ain't gonna make it anyway
if you were that close to the edge
anyway so it's more political hogwash
than it is anything makes everybody feel
better and makes the market feel better
and I'm not if they want to do it it's
okay but for giving ten thousand dollars
of your student loan debt doesn't fix
your financial run you are gonna fix
your financial problem and that message
is not changed around here the people
that have debt and no savings they're
finding out that this idea that there's
good debt is bogus because this is when
their stupid ideas stress-test ago every
time there's debt it accelerates the
volatility in your life and in the
nation's life because the consumer is so
leveraged and the consumer has no
savings and so you know one two-week
period of time with no pay and you're
just completely devastated right and so
what happened to me because I was stupid
was I had that same thing happened only
wasn't a two-week period of time I made
$200,000 one year in my 20s the next
year I made $6,000 in the process of
losing everything we owned and I
discovered I this leverage I borrowed
money wasn't my friend it was only my
friend when everything went perfect and
never does everything go perfect and not
having any cash was a dumb idea
not having granite grandma's rainy day
fund it's gonna rain dummy that's what
that's what I kept saying to myself and
so I changed that and thank God I did
all those years ago and I've talked a
few of you out there if you million of
you out there into doing that and hmm
and so you're sitting there right now
kind of feeling like wow this stuff
works I'm really glad that all these
people that made fun of me my broke
friends when they were making fun of me
for cutting up my credit cards because I
didn't get the airline miles but rough
line on it right now
yeah and you're supposed to be in your
home suckin your thumb you're not
supposed to be flying on an airplane and
so no trouble social distancing on them
though because nobody's on them but you
know the but you see the thing I mean
it's that the the the everything is is
exponentially more volatile in our
economy and in our personal homes the
more debt we have and in other words
debt equals risk now this is not
something that you have not said and I
have not said that's exactly right we
have been saying this and now we're
observing it like a bunch of lab rats
well and Dave and and people are feeling
it and hearing it on another level now
yeah and it's crazy I've heard you say
this before that you have to get to your
uncle point you know and I have uncle's
in where they would get me in holds and
get me in that point where I would say
I'm a bagel it was a little a little
a little Korean but unfortunately this
is what requires us to wake up and
really and truly not just talk about
change but be about change in our lives
and I'm talking to people that'll say
Chris this has never happened to me
again yeah this feel whenever again
never again when you have that never
again moment that's her again will
American Express call my house and this
was a wrong number because I'm not doing
business with them never again no matter
what I will never be in a position
without cash from my emergency fund no
matter what no one's gonna come and
collect my car out of the driveway
unless it's because I called them and it
was broken you know no one no matter
what right and that's what happened to
me because I was stupid
and I got myself into a mess and some of
y'all huh we Kris and I are not you know
no one at Ramsey's gonna get up in your
face and say I've told you so it up
thump our chest about how smart we are
we understand that this is your wake-up
call this is your unique moment in time
and you're gonna look back and go thank
God for the coronavirus it changed my
life
mmm when you look back 10 years from now
if you will just take this moment in
time to change you will look at this and
say thank God
like I say thank God I went bankrupt in
my 20s does it change my life cuz I was
stupid and I got my wake-up call thank
God for it